HE WILL TAKE IT.
AND THE E R.
THROUGH HIS OWN FEE TOTO Jim: S
MOVING UP.
TIPPED FROM BEHIND.
RIGHT BACK TO FITZGERALD CAME OT
IT WAS IN PA.
LOOK OUT.
THEY SCORE.
A LINE CHANGE.R KONECNY.
GOES THROUGH.
A ONE  NODDING HIS HEAD
TAPPING AWAY. OBBED D THERE BY
NO WHISTLE.
KEEPS PLAYING.
IT WILL BE A GOAL.
PROBABLY  NOAH CATES' GO.
HE IS THE REASON THE
THERE YOU
SHOT -- HE SCORES.
SANDSTROM SLIDING ACROSS.
OLOFSSON GOT ENOUGH OF IT  OLOFE
FIRES THE ONE-TIMER AGAIN.
N THE SECOND.
THOMPSON WITTO FINISH -- IT WIDE
MITTELSTADT TURNS.
FINDS ANOTHE
HE SHOOTS.
THEY SCORE.
SANHEIM.
SHOT.
SAVE.
HIGH IN THEY WERE OUT OF GAS.
THAT WAS AN INTERESTING TIME
OUSEAL
THE DEAL